I want to find out a little bit more
about this exit by Carl Icahn a backflip
yeah i mean at the time that he got
involved in netflix was a very different
business it was a business was going
through this transition of mailing DVDs
DVDs streaming oh yes we remember those
yes and going through the transition and
and what's interesting about it is he
yelled us talking the time that a lot of
the big cost for netflix still have yet
to sort of hit the income statement
there that they're even
off-balance-sheet their commitments and
contingencies where they've promised to
to buy a lot of content they don't put
those costs on there that obligation on
their balance sheets or those costs
still yet to hit the company we don't
know quite when they're gonna well how
big they're gonna be because some of
them are depending on how much stuff is
watched his cult icon or was he a very
active shareholder when it came to
Netflix or did he kind of stay in the
background is not the carl icahn of you
know getting very involved a company
today getting very involved a managed of
breaking up companies this is not it and
this indeed may have been much more of
his sons investment than Carl's
Instagram Facebook versus Twitter I
think this really big news on Instagram
they're making a big people with
Instagram in is what exam is an app that
used by 300 million people who post 70
million secretly on shares all right
okay post there's an Instagram posting
pictures online that other people can
view and what's one of the things they
do is a lot of people explore find other
people to follow find interesting things
to look at but they're making some
changes about the way that people able
to discover things that are happening
they use hashtags in the same way that
twitter does but they're going to do
more things in terms of finding out with
their explore button the reefer they're
changing this in a way to allow you to
find out what's happening around them or
in certain places and the notion the
Kevin Systrom who runs the business on
facebook says it's really a shot at
Twitter they really think that they can
they can take this business and have
people use Instagram to follow what's
happening in live events and follow
what's happening in things that are
happening as they happen and be much
more of a broadcasting medium in the way
that Twitter is used for people to
follow live events and because right now
Instagram is kind of for the masses it's
certainly made its way into consumers
minds that whereas Twitter doesn't
necessarily have that same entree and
now Instagram is going for more niche
audience is that right i think the more
what their imagines that they're gonna
be the instrument we the place you
follow what's happening in the world
and the same way that some of us would
go to look at that Twitter for news that
Instagram thinks that it can be the same
thing Yahoo shareholder meeting Alibaba
update for me shareholder meetings okay
if you're invested in yahoo you want the
tax free distribution of your Alibaba
share right there's all these concerns
about the IRS and what they said in
regarding the possibility of these times
brisbane austin or in as much as we
might get any news out of this thing and
that's a big if shareholder meeting
today cheryl meeting today if we get any
news out of this thing you look for the
exact language that they use last week
marissa meyer talked to our stuff he
made at our tech conference in san
francisco and was very careful in the
words that she chose to talk about the
Alibaba spin-off saying that they do I
RS didn't start there look at these
things just to look at alibaba but she
didn't exclude the possibility would
make change she suggested I'm sure a lot
of lawyers in the audience you don't
want to say anything back well will we
will be listening to see if there's any
news about the Alibaba spin-off as it
relates to the taxes in particular